wow that's like so accurate how the heck
are these quizzes always so accurate
it's so scary
hi my name is paris burals and i play v
in one of them my name is nicholas
coombe and i play owen my name is dj
mausner and i'm playing diane i'm steven
joffe and i'm playing ricardo my name is
madison baines and i play lily i'm
lolita molina and i play jenna i'm
taylor zack r perez and i play dustin my
name is hari neff and i play sloane
today we're finding out which one up
character we are through a buzzfeed quiz
question number one how would you
describe yourself in one word sarcastic
dorky confident ambitious kind resilient
well i'm definitely not kind definitely
not confident
no i'm just kidding i'm gonna go with
resilient so because i'm australian i
think i have to go with sarcastic i mean
i think the most important thing on this
is kind so i'm gonna stay kind yeah i
would say you are incredibly kind i
picked kind i'm gonna say ambitious oh
yeah you're definitely confident you're
very confident
oh no i'm gonna go sarcastic for me yeah
actually i think resilient and dorky
dorky
actually you do be like playing zelda
alone up in your room maybe you are
dorky um but i'm gonna put resilient i'm
gonna put ambitious i think you're hell
ambitious i am yeah okay next question
what's your worst personality trait
you're stubborn you don't speak up you
take on too much
you push people away you're ego driven
or you're brash
i'm gonna go with stubborn stubborn as
well i'm pretty stubborn i think that
i'm very stubborn so i'm gonna say that
i think i don't speak up
that's not the case yeah um i'm going to
say i'm ego driven i'm ego driven really
you don't feel that way i don't think
that your ego oh i might be brash i'm
changing it i'm going to be brash okay i
can see that because you're not afraid
to speak about like how you feel about
something no constantly i'm stubborn as
a mule whenever i make up my mind so
i don't know
maybe i don't you don't speak up stuff
i think it's time for therapy taylor
i'm brash yeah you're not saying if you
could have one superpower what would it
be super strength time travel mind
reading invisibility flight
shape-shifting or having an amazing
friend like dj i get to have an amazing
friend like me yeah
no sorry they just took that off again
oh time travel would be sick i could do
so many things with time travel i can go
back and
share my first kiss again oh my gosh
i'm gonna go shape-shifting
shape-shifting for sure i'm gonna go
with mind reading mind reading and i'm
gonna go with flight because i'm still a
six-year-old boy
i might do flight i'm kind of afraid of
flying in airplanes but like i look at
birds i'm like they're so confident up
there i don't wanna do that i just would
love to see you with wings man like a
fairy or like a pegasus
whatever you want all right
how do you handle conflict meet fire
with fire avoid at all costs retreat
into yourself play the peacemaker with
ease and confidence you actively seek it
out i unfortunately meet fire with fire
i add oil to the flames i'm gonna say
with ease and confidence i
hate conflict so i'm gonna go i avoid it
at all costs i think i'm pretty good
with conflict so i'm gonna say play the
peacemaker i totally believe that i
normally play the peacemaker yeah i
agree with that for you the last time i
met conflict i used fire with fire so i
will say play the peacemaker because
that was the last thing that i
did you know what i'm changing it to
ease in confidence i'm gonna say meet
fire with fire steve's passionate i'm a
passionate guy what's your favorite
animal tigers unicorn bird house cat
koala dolphin there's no dogs on here i
don't see a fox or a bat on here i love
bats you're more of a tiger that's like
the closest scary animal they have
i'm gonna go with tiger tiger i have a
tattoo of a tiger no way i do let's go
big one on my back i would like to pick
koala because i'm aussie but i'm not
gonna although they're cool they all
have they have chlamydia chlamydia so
i'm gonna go with koala no koalas all
have chlamydia i got a dolphin yeah
dolphins are super smart they can like
read
i'm gonna go with uh dolphin dolphins i
like sea dogs you know they're like the
happy guys they protect you so then
let's go get you a dolphin tattoo
yeah i'm picking unicorn they're all
over me i have a house cat named daisy
and she's lovely so i'm gonna say house
cat daisy
finally if you were a video game
character who'd you be link sonic lara
croft
bowser yoshi or samus
gotta pick my girl lara croft that was
one of the reasons why i wanted to
become an actor it was angelina jolie in
tomb raider no way
actually i have to go lara croft because
i love tomb raider i'm probably gonna go
with link i own with link so i've been
picking link in super smash brothers
since i was a child i'm gonna say samus
because samus's gender is like
my boy yoshi's on here i love him so
much he's so cute
i would play samus in like the metroid
film adaptation that is like my dream
samus all the way
oh wait i just clicked on it
yes you got diane oh that's amazing i
knew hold on
i'm you
she got herself i got flown i got sloane
you're cool confident and witty af while
others may struggle to balance all their
responsibilities you're a bonafide
expert when it comes to juggling work
study and social life plus you don't
stand for any [ __ ] if someone rubs
you the wrong way you're not afraid to
call them out thank you for casting me
well based on the text i got owen i got
owen he was played by nick who's like
the sweetiest bobediest man on this
planet it says you're a sweetheart at
your core yeah a kind conscious
individual who wants to better yourself
yeah heck yeah but you don't always
immediately stand up for what you
believe in
i'm working on it i'm gonna get better
this is the year particularly when it
means having to go up against your peers
wow that's like so accurate that's scary
you make the best decisions when you
follow your heart not your head how the
heck are these quizzes always so
accurate it's so scary
i'm gonna be honest that surprises me
yeah i am not afraid to go against my
peers and be like i don't know about
that it makes me happy that like i hope
i'm a good person and you know i feel
like we all need to always be working on
ourselves so i'm i'm happy with that
answer
oh i amv
you are a natural-born leader someone
who fights for what is right and is
skilled at rallying a crowd but you can
make hasty decisions on impulse which
sometimes gets you in trouble wow you
are ambitious clever and a fiercely
loyal friend
that's so true yeah that's that's me i
see how the casting process went now
they were just like paris
this i'm just playing me you got diane
you've gotten used to hearing that
you're a bit of a handful but your ott
energy and hyper enthusiasm always comes
from a good place you'd proudly call
yourself a dork because you just see
that as another word for passionate look
i wouldn't say that it's accurate but
maybe that's because i'm not kind enough
to myself i love that you got my
character i love that i got your
character take the quiz to find out
which one up character you are whether
you're a gamer or not check out wanna